This video is brought to you by news voice, the news is broken.
All us media is owned by just a handful of big corporations.
Fake news is obviously a huge problem as well.
And finding something and biased can be really hard.
News voice is revolutionizing the news landscape.
It's an app that gives you a personalized newsfeed by aggregating major new
sites,
as well as international and independent media giving some much needed balance.
Each new story shows multiple sources,
which are all tagged with their bias and perspective.
The news affects almost everything in our lives,
what we hear and what we read shapes, which persons we trust, what we eat,
what we buy, how we vote,
and even what we think news voice is created by its readers. As you can,
upvote stories that you find interesting. So more people will see them.
It's essentially a democratized platform for news. Plus it saves you time.
You get all the news and all the sources in one app so that you can be better
informed and it's totally free. Anyway,
get started with news voice today for free through the link below it's available
on both Google play and the Apple app store. And let's get into the.
Friends.
The story you're about to see is not the script of an Eastern European spy film.
It is what has happened and what is happening today in the heart of Russian
politics. And the fact is that to the Russian Federation,
the country of [inaudible] vodka and the mythical Kalinka song,
we could just as easily add poison to that list of the country's defining
features. Yes, yes, that's right poison by now.
I'm pretty sure that you have all heard stories like this.
Russia's Navani fell ill after drinking from poisoned water bottle in his hotel
room eight, say CNN.
Alex say Navani who we discussed not long ago on visual politic has basically
become the main enemy of president Vladimir Putin within contemporary Russian
politics and enemy who Putin has become more and more obsessed with.
As this character has been able to unite to the opposition and create what is
possibly the strongest alternative to the Russian ruler in a long, long time,
by the way,
I'll leave the link to the video that we made recently about Navani in the
description below. Well,
the point is that daring to confront the powerful Vladimir Putin has its risks
in a country where the rule of law is virtually absent and the secret services
do as they please,
it should come as no surprise that the elimination of opponents is.
Commonplace.
Think about attacks against influential people, such as politicians,
journalists, activists, and even artists who do not agree with the government.
And remember that these attacks don't only happen on Russian soil,
but also abroad.
Many of you probably remember the case of the poisoning of Sergei and Yulia
scrip pal in Saulsbury,
UK by two Russian agents in 2018 and attack for which they used a nerve agent
called a two, three, four from the novel shock group. In other words,
we're talking about the fact that we have witnessed real chemical weapon
attacks.
Foreign soil.
I don't think for a moment that this poisoning is something new in mother,
Russia, not at all. In fact,
these techniques have been part of the politics of this country for much longer
than you might think to give you a couple of examples. In 1453,
Prince Dimitri sham Yucca was eliminated by poisoning when his chicken dinner
was laced with arsenic in 16, 10,
another Russian Prince Mikayla's scorpion shoe whiskey was poisoned by his own
wife because the SAR considered him a threat.
And the truth is that since then poisoning has been a constant in Russia and in
factually reached an age of excellence with the arrival of the Soviet union.
Yeah.
Lennon himself,
the father of the Russian Bolshevik movement promoted the creation of a network
of secret laboratories to research and develop new poisons.
And then during the Stalin era, many more were added.
The most famous was lab X popularly known as Camaro.
The initial objective of these laboratories was to test and perfect existing
poisons and objective for which they did not hesitate in using life.
Prisoners held in their GoogleX, who were poisoned with mustard, gas,
rice in digit, in Cura and cyanide among many other toxic agents.
All of this following closely the style of Dr. Mengele or the Japanese seven
three one squadron
And take notes because once they had the knowledge and the capacity,
what is possibly one of the most horrible and frightening arms races of the
entire Soviet era was set in motion, the chemical weapons race.
Listen up
the Soviets shadiest heritage.
One question.
Why are poisons used against the opposition so frequently in Russia? Well,
I'm sure it's pretty obvious to make sure the obstacle is fully eliminated,
but why use poisons and toxic agents instead of other methods? Well,
think about it for a moment.
We're talking about the fast silent method with effects on the human body that
mimic those of a natural death. And in fact,
progress in the creation of lethal substances that could go completely
undetected advanced very, very quickly.
Yeah.
1928 And 1935,
the secret Soviet laboratories of biochemist Grigory,
[inaudible] managed to create a wide catalog of tasteless, colorless, odorless,
and lethal poisons that could be poured into food or drink without the victim
being aware of their presence.
Thanks to the advances he was making Myra Navasky became part of the team,
or [inaudible] an agent of the Soviet and KVD secret service,
which was dedicated to executing anyone, considered an enemy of the state.
State.
And this in fact was what allowed Sue to play it off and its team to change
their modus operandi.
They played with bizarre methods like giving away boxes of chocolates containing
explosives,
just simply spicing up an enemy's food or drink with one of their custom
poisons. It was so simple that they quickly got the hang of it.
And poisoning became one of the main methods of annihilation against dissent in
the Soviet union. By the way, after Stalin's death,
suitor plateau was arrested in the context of stylization.
He spent 15 years in prison.
Of course the Soviets were well aware that such methods were effective.
So despite their condemnation,
it didn't take them long to devote more and more resources to developing new
substances, which were becoming more potent and more difficult to treat.
Right.
But why on earth? Did they need other poisons, more discrete ones? Well,
friends, the answer to this question is given by historian Boris [inaudible].
They must make the victim's debts or illness appear natural,
or at least produce symptoms that will baffled doctors and forensic
investigators. To this end,
to the Camaro developed its defining specialty combining known poisons into
original and untraceable forms, Loris Villa Dark-Sky.
Of course, as the poisons advanced.
So did medical and forensic techniques as we've doping in sport,
it was a struggle, a continuous effort to stay. One step ahead,
fast began a whole race to develop poisons more and more secretively up until
that point. However,
it had remained relatively common to use methods such as polonium two,
one Oh a toxic substance that leaves a wide trail of radioactive contamination
that is easy to track with a Geiger counter that led the Soviets to launch a
nerve agent development program that was unique in the world. In the 1980s,
friends falling into is born the program that created the dreaded Nova chalk
agents Over chalk,
which literally means newcomer in Russian is a group of highly lethal
neurotoxins developed by Soviet scientists in laboratories in Northern Catholic.
Stan is Pakistan and in Russia itself carried in the form of a liquid powder or
aerosol.
They are extremely easy poisons to transport to another country in order to
eliminate even exiled dissonance without being detected at international
borders.
This group of poisons inhibits Colin Estrace like attacking neuro-transmitters,
which are substances in the nerve cells that regulates the essential functions
of the body.
This causes a failure in an essential organ that can be masked as a coincidental
illness. In addition,
these poisons have the advantage that depending on the dose used conserve both
to end life or to scare rivals with warnings,
that is to cause harm without eliminating the
Who could prove in Soviet times that the cause of the ailment was the workings
of the state. And not just a sudden illness, I assure you that no one could,
this is why no one knows exactly how many people the USSR could have been
employed with this type of secret operation against opponents and dissidents.
But friends, let's be very clear about one thing,
the programs and equipment to carry out these operations existed.
So surely the victim tally is in the thousands.
Any case.
What is clear is that today this modus operandi is alive and well in Putin's
Russia as well,
either because he is a tough guy or because he's a former KGB agent.
It seems that the Russian president loves to break out the poisons to prove that
you are either with him or against him. And in fact, the FSB,
the Russian federal security service has inherited not only the structures,
but also the methods of the KGB.
And no one seems able or to want to do anything about it.
But how is it possible that in the 21st century and with all the medical
advances that have been made this archaic and ancient method of eliminating
adversaries still exists. And another question,
is there any reaction or resistance in Russian society when such a case comes to
light? Well.
[Inaudible].
New Russia, old habits.
If there is one thing Putin likes to show off to his friends,
it is surely the fact that no one can touch him.
The events within an outside Russia under the presidency of this new species of
SAR shows us that his methods and his mentality have not stopped evolving every
year that he has been at the helm of the Kremlin,
the factors that Putin who first became president of Russia back in 1999,
and since then has not relinquished power has been crossing more and more
ethical and moral lines. For example, in 2004,
Russia poisoned the former president of Ukraine pro European Victor U Shanko.
When he was in the middle of his election campaign.
This was discovered after you Shanko suddenly developed acute pancreatitis as a
result, doctors in Vienna, where he was treated,
discovered such high levels of TCD dioxin in his body,
that it became the second highest level ever measured in a human being.
A couple of years later, Alexander Litvinenko,
a former KGB agent residing in London who was anti Putin died of radioactive
poisoning. Of course,
in order to understand the possible relationship between this event and the
Russian government, you have to go back one month to October, 2006,
when Russian journalist,
Anna Pollitt coughs Gaia was shot in the elevator of her apartment.
It.
Yeah, it was an anti Putin journalist who always got around threats, censorship,
and all the other obstacles,
the Russian government put in the way of doing her job.
That was until she started investigating Putin's crimes in the Chechnya and
various corruption cases that apparently made her a priority targets.
One that had to be silenced. And in fact, all those Ubers killed in October,
2006,
a couple of years before that she had been poisoned on an Aeroflot flight with a
poison that remains undetermined to this day.
The journalist began to feel very unwell after drinking tea on board the
aircraft. However, in that case,
the prompt actions of the crew and an emergency landing safe.
Life.
The fact is that Alexander Litvinenko decided from London to investigate the
strange circumstances of Politkovskaya his death in the elevator of her house.
And only a month later,
he himself died from poisoning the method polonium 200 poisoning after
meeting with two Russians in a London hotel who were allegedly business
contacts, the trace of radio activity, however, was left all over the room.
And not only that,
but also on the stairs of the hotel and in a nearby discotheque where the
Russian agents had been a towel loaded with radioactivity even turned up in the
laundry.
All these traces in fact were precisely what it helps Scotland yard to know
where the killers had been and when the poisoning had occurred.
However, if what you've heard already seemed serious,
the truth is that since then, things have only gotten worse. For example,
an activist and journalist who has spoken out against Putin,
Vladimir Kara Mercer has been poisoned twice once in 2015, and again,
in 2017 becoming seriously ill POS of a seal, a, right?
Activists suddenly lost his sight hearing and mobility in 2018 and was later
confirmed as having been poisoned when he traveled to Germany for treatment in
the same year,
Sergei and Yulia ScripPal were poisoned with a nerve agent from the novice shock
group in Salisbury, UK, as we mentioned at the beginning of this video.
And most recently, as you all know, there is the case of Alexa.
And Elvani.
As you can see,
this is a long list of known cases that has escalated in the last five years.
And that's without counting the cases of poisoning within the country itself and
carried out on people, not as prominent as the opposition leader.
Let's just say that what happens in Russia stays in Russia.
One of poisons, great virtues for the politically minded murderers,
their capacity to combine easy deniability and vicious theatricality.
Even while the murder denies any role, perhaps with a sly wink,
the victim dies a horrific and often lengthy death,
a message in a poison bottle, Mark Delhi,
Opti senior associate fellow at the Royal United services Institute.
Friends.
One key factor that runs throughout this story is that the cases we know about
we only know about because they either occurred outside of Russia,
all the victims managed to go abroad for medical treatment.
How many more cases can go undetected within Russia itself? It is difficult,
very difficult, practically impossible to find out, but okay, at this point,
the question that comes up is, and in the meantime,
what does the Russian government make of all this?
Well, you can probably.
The imagine of course they know nothing. And certainly what the instigators,
maybe it was the work of a personal enemy,
a fatal attraction situation answers that at the end of the day are not at all
convincing. Isn't it.
Hearing this argument for like many years from political Skyah to lift the
Namco, to scrape all that. It could not possibly be the Kremlin,
but someone trying to please the Kremlin.
But the problem with this argument is that in 2020,
the situation is not what it was in 2004, 2006.
It's really difficult to imagine that somebody would dare do something that
drastic and not first secure some kind of agreement to be sure that he or she
is on the safe side, Andre Soldatov expert on the Russian security.
It makes perfect sense. Doesn't it? But, okay.
I'm sure many of you are also asking yourselves, okay, Josh,
but what about the people?
What do the regular Russian citizens think about all this?
Well,
that question is also somewhat difficult to answer because the truth is that
Russian society, if it has learned anything over the last century,
is that when it comes to matters of power, it's better to keep your ears,
eyes and mouth shut. Nevertheless, in spite of this,
the opposition reap good results in the regional elections on 13 for September,
2020, Navani's allies,
one regional representatives for the first time in history and made United
Russia Putin's party lose the majority in two Siberian cities and
Marvis a bit. But in any case,
the truth is that to express yourself actively is not only something extremely
dangerous for Russians in terms of repression and political consequences.
It is also difficult for them to find protection.
The information blackout in this respect is practically total.
So you see the consequences of going off script are pretty much those you have
seen in this video. So from all of the visual politic team,
our thoughts and our respect goes to all those people that have lost their lives
or have risked their lives fighting for a freer and more democratic Russia.
But at this point,
how do you think the international community should act against the poisoning of
the Russian opposition should Russian operations to kill opponents abroad,
to be considered a violation of sovereignty against the foreign nation.
As always, we ask the questions and you provide the answers.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine. Also.
This channel was possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll be seeing you in the next week.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.
[Inaudible].